[Music]
besides being
a designer i've also been an educator
for many years
you can consider me a modern day
polymath
[Music]
i don't really understand what design
meant
then but the visuals were very
attractive to me
so i ended up studying architecture in
the university
and i actually started my first fencing
in school and i sold it for one dollar
to all my friends
so i think that really sparked my
interest
in publishing and eventually led me into
the road of
entrepreneurship and design
each was started in 1999 at that point
of time there were no
platforms for young designers to
showcase their works and talents so i
wanted to create
ish as a platform to showcase local
talents
local designs to give them that platform
to shine
when i started my nd and 15 minutes it
was with the same vision of providing
a creative platform for singapore
designers and creatives
to have a space to showcase their talent
this is my way of
kind of like contributing to the
singapore design ecosystem
and also my personal way of contributing
to the design scene
over the years i've come to reflect that
my practice
is a lot about documentation and
archival
of the singapore design scene and i hope
to continue this
documentation and archiver on an online
platform called studio sml
and this website will document all young
and old designers
of all disciplines before they shine and
before they die
i've dedicated my life to being a
designer and educator
winning the pda means that i'll continue
to do the same
but also to serve as an advocate and
ambassador for the design industry
i'm grateful for the opportunity that i
have
to mentor many young designers and to
share my knowledge over the years
and for me i will always bear in mind
that the first role of a designer is to
serve
you